au bout des ongles un radio amateur
américain communiqué que le monde entier
c'est le terrain de jeu des adhérents du
radio club de montigny un jeu sérieux et
très encadrés ils ont tous un indicatif
radio amateur c'est une personne qui a
une attirance pour les
communications
par radio et aussi pour les technologies
l'électronique l'informatique la
mécanique et qui souhaite donc échangé
par radio avec d'autres radios amateurs
proches ou plus loin lancé en
1974 le club s'adapte en fonction de
l'évolution des technologies mais aussi
des compétences de chaque radio amateur
le radio club fait aussi de la formation
auprès des futurs passionnés et organise
des conférences on a eu l'idée de faire
une conférence sur une parabole qui est
à la cité des sciences de la villette
qui a été prise en charge par un groupe
de radio amateur il ya au moins une
douzaine d'années et c'est une parabole
gigantesque cette ville at fait 10
mètres de diamètre cette parabole a été
restaurée et permet de faire de la radio
astronomie de lait coûte donc d'onde qui
viennent de l'espace les locaux unis
montrent un héberge l'adrasec et des
amateurs au service de la sécurité
civile
la radio est un outil pour la sécurité
et en k2 en cas de crise et tous et nous
radio matters certains mettent à
disposition leurs matériels leurs
compétences leur temps à leurs moyens
pour apporter un soutien supplémentaire
aux
la sécurité civile ils sont 70 adhérents
à se réunir chaque semaine pour partager
leur passion utilisation des conditions
climatiques du morse du système wifi et
même de la lune les radioamateurs sont
des touche-à-tout